new couple alert a source confirms to ET
that Kylie Jenner and Timothy chalamet
are dating but keeping things casual I
can't
ET Source says it's not serious but
Kylie is enjoying hanging out with the
Oscar nominee and seeing where it goes
it's been really fun for her because it
feels a lot different than her past
relationships it's new and exciting for
Kylie that's what it is to
be young this all comes three months
after E.T learned the beauty Mogul and
her on and off boyfriend Travis Scott
we're off again the former couple shares
two children together five-year-old
daughter stormy come give me a hug
I love you mommy it looks forever and
one-year-old son air who was originally
named wolf I liked the name I don't
think
I just wasn't him back in January A
source told E.T the two have had an up
and down relationship explaining that
they live different Lifestyles and
that's been a big issue with two kids
Kylie doesn't go out too much Travis on
the other hand lives a life of late
nights in the studio and going out with
friends
then in March A source told ET that
Kylie is trying to stay positive doing
her own thing and wants to keep things
cordial with Travis for the sake of
their family she wants things to be
balanced and remain drama-free see
that's what I'm talking about as for
Kylie and Timothy neither one has
addressed the romance publicly and they
haven't stepped out in an official way
there were Rumblings online that maybe
they'd make their big debut at Coachella
but ET Source says Kylie really just
wanted to chill and have fun with her
friends at the festival not draw
attention to herself
to be really work
representing ourselves as for how they
met her sister Kendall Jenner may have
had something to do with it oursource
says Kendall and Timothy are friends so
it's been easy for Kylie to integrate
him into her life I mean it's awesome
well we'll just have to wait and see how
the romance plays out but in the
meantime we're counting down the days
until the Kardashian season 3 premieres
on Hulu and yes we'll be keeping an eye
out for Timothy Cameo I wish I could
tell you this is going to be a mild
relaxing Serene season
it's not
okay